shocking footage out of Birmingham
Alabama capture the terrifying moments a
high school band director has tased
multiple times in front of dozens of
students
the incident happened on September 14th
after a local football game according to
the Birmingham Police Department the
football game had been over for more
than 10 minutes and officers were
attempting to get the high school band
to vacate the stadium one Birmingham
police officer approaches one of the
instructors from the Minor High School
band and tells them they have to leave
father
[Applause]
s
as the band music plays louder that's
when the officer approaches another man
later identified as high school band
director Johnny Mims
[Music]
have a place
after the officer issues another warning
to Mims to wrap up a second officer
approaches Mims to issue the same
warning and says they will get the
school involved if they don't leave
[Applause]
okay
after going back and forth with the
officers memes signals the band to keep
playing their song
[Applause]
[Music]
despite the continuous warnings Delights
to the football field are then shut off
but mems continues to let the song play
out to the very last note
let's go
[Applause]
seconds later a confrontation happens as
police attempt to arrest Mims
[Applause]
see what appears to be a student tell
officers to leave Mims alone
the scuffle continues as police get a
handcuff on mems but are unable to
secure the other side
[Applause]
he got to go to jail
you look
a male officer can be heard issuing a
final warning to Mims that he's going to
jail and that's when he deploys his
taser three times
[Applause]
the Birmingham Police Department says
Mims was treated at the scene and taken
to a local hospital before being
transported to jail he was arrested and
charged with disorderly conduct
harassment and resisting arrest
Johnny Mims told ABC's Good Morning
America that the police used excessive
force and that he feared for his life
the Birmingham Police Department's
Internal Affairs division is
investigating the incident
for the long crime Network I'm Elizabeth
Milner